okay I think that means that I am live
now h Hello everybody welcome to
um welcome to my live stream for uh my
my live stream Q&A for February been
doing this every month for the last four
months this is an hour when y'all get to
ask me whatever questions you have on
your mind about flow arts or anything
else for that
matter um and I will do my best to
answer them um
yeah as you
are uh dropping
me questions in the chat one thing to
bear in mind is that hi dizzy one thing
to bear in mind is that um you can leave
me a tip with the Super Chat that is
that button that looks like um a little
square with a dollar sign in it that
money comes directly to me um so it
would be much appreciated and anybody
who um anybody who leaves me a super
chat I will bump your question up in the
queue
um so that it gets answered sooner
because generally speaking uh I tend to
be very very long- winded in my answers
overall so uh sometimes it can be
helpful to be able to jump the queue on
that or if you don't care about jumping
the queue it just helps out the channel
so uh Ras I'm not even going to
try Okay so if the pronunciation rules
are the same between Lithuanian and
Czech that would be Ras Vish
vishas
vnos so maybe we'll see uh saying hello
glad to see you love from Lithuanian
flowarts Community thank you uh
greetings from Washington
DC um thank you for joining me tonight
Jillian says Hi I can hear and see you
outstanding I'm glad to hear it I'm glad
to hear it um cool so I'm going to I'm
honestly just going to let people start
rolling in here and
um you know ask whatever questions they
have in their mind and while that
happens I'm honestly just going to take
a few minutes to flow out cuz why the
heck not I have not gotten a chance
really to do that today so why not do it
while I'm waiting for people to come and
join us so once again if you got
questions please drop them in the chat
let me know what you got on your mind I
will do my best to answer
them I should really have music on while
I'm doing
this I don't know if it'll come through
on the speakers here um yeah so please
drop me those uh please drop me those
questions in the
chat and I will uh I'm going to I will
put on a song for me to flow to and when
I'm done flowing I will check and
see what's been asked and uh answer some
questions
there oh interesting
[Music]
what's playing I do not know it is just
what iTunes thought I wanted to listen
to kick up the volume just a little bit
here
I'm thinking about you
night running around with your friend
now the pieces
my
FL you
baby but I can't
take my life
[Applause]
[Music]
I
you
take baby that ain't for me that ain't
for me oh all around the
morning
[Applause]
theow but tonight I st my where so you
go
[Applause]
when I
you when I
[Applause]
got down
[Music]
baby but tonight I save my life
[Applause]
so my life when I told you
[Music]
all right let's see what popped up in
the chat while I was flowing
there stop
playing
ah all right all right
so roas roas says uh thank you for your
work in tutorials I have been taking
your methods to teach other students and
they are brilliant thank you just want
to say a big thank you you are the
teacher of Po flow and mechanics I
appreciate that thanks a lot uh
Ras Dizzy's giving me heart eyes there I
appreciate it I appreciate it nobody had
any questions while I was doing all that
oh goodness um
um well maybe people have questions now
please drop them in the chat and do
remember God I've got to stop doing
pettes in my socks on this carpet
because I've been I've been tearing
holes in the balls of uh of my
socks and I now have just like a handful
of sets that
um that don't have holes in the I can I
can feel I've been wearing through the
soles of uh of this set of socks so
whoops um yeah so send me your questions
and I will answer them to the best of my
capacity
um and uh yeah once again Super Chat
supports the channel so don't be shy
about using that that is the button with
the uh uh with the square and the dollar
sign inside of it so uh Jillian asks um
oh now the questions are rolling in
great uh Jillian asks how do you do a
reverse weave behind your back um so
here's a thing the uh the instructions
that I give on how to do a behind the
back
weave if you're looking real
carefully uh relative to me this is a
reverse weave like when I start the p on
my sides I swear that the PO are going
reverse so when I get into it um sure
feels to me like it's a reverse weave
the challenge is of course that relative
to being behind me it looks like it's a
forwards weave it looks identical to
this motion right here so one of those
things to understand is that the rules
of what's a reverse versus forwards
weave when we go behind our backs kind
of get turned inside
out so I'm pretty sure the question
you're actually asking is how do you do
um a weave behind the back that starts
from a place where it feels like the poy
are spinning forwards on your sides cuz
that does wind up resembling hang on uh
what we think of as being a reverse
weave when we bring it around in front
of
us so the step steps behind this
actually are pretty close to the exact
same steps that we would use for getting
um the other behind the back weave uh so
like normally when we start learning the
behind the back weave we start with the
Poise spinning forwards and we walk
around in a circle until we can get our
arm wrapped around behind us and the PO
spinning reverse on our sides we switch
up that convention now uh we start with
the Poise spinning reverse on our side
and we walk around and try to get to a
point where we can get the Poise
spinning forwards on the side of us with
our arm wrapped around behind our back
we want to learn how to do this not just
with the right hand but
also with the left
hand like
so
and just like we do when we're working
on it going the other direction um we
are trying to do this in such a way
where like there there's a point at
which the oops that was the wrong
direction um there's a point at which we
kind of have to flip the orientation of
our wrist as we're going around and we
have to get comfortable uh hanging out
with uh with our hand behind our back
like this the Poise seeming like it's
spinning forwards relative to us um once
you get that down the next step is from
the Poise spinning
forward
uh I'm messing me myself up here no PO
spinning reverse on your your side you
work on oh my goodness see this is this
is uh this is starting to to mess with
my head now too um yeah there we go
so
nope yes there we go that's the one
that's the one yeah so with the po po
starting off going forwards on your side
you want to try and get down Tic
Tacs going behind your back like this
you want to try and get that down with
each
hand this one's really obnoxious I'm not
going to lie I do not like the way this
one
feels and then once you got that down
you work on getting down your Tic Tacs
or your two beat weaves uh going behind
your back so um when we start from po
going reverse and work on our two beat
weaves we're start the hand that starts
it is the hand that goes under uh now
the hand that starts it is the hand that
goes over so like that so if my left
hand is starting it off that means my
left hand is going to be on top if my
right hand starts it off whoops that
means my right hand winds up on top like
so so you want to be able to get down
having either hand on top as you're
working your way through this here and
then you go through the pattern of
um just like we do with a reverse weave
where we're going under over back under
over back uh you do the same thing
behind your back where you are going
under over back under over back under
over back under over back with your
right hand same thing with your left
thinking under over back under over back
un oop
under under over back what do I mean by
under over back it means where your hand
is going relative to your other hand so
when it switches sides it starts off
going underneath your hand and then over
your hand and then back under over back
under over
back again we
have under
over under over back under over back
like so once you got that down with both
hands you can start to work on getting
down the full
weave and generally speaking it's easy
the best way to do this is not to just
jump into it like I just did but to kind
of think okay I'm going to do right hand
under over back so we do under over back
and I'm going to do left hand under over
back so we do H goodness under over back
and then as you go back and forth
between those eventually you get to a
point where you can just keep the thing
going why do people always want to learn
behind the back tricks they hurt they
suck I hate doing
them anyhow that's how you do the other
behind the
back weave there
Jillian cool so
youan I ril V viam marzo how to do five
beat
weaves okay um so five beat
weaves I personally think the best way
to do five beat weaves is to work on
just like adding an extra beat on each
side of your body before bringing them
together so when we do three beat weaves
we're essentially working inside of a
place where we have the left hand cross
over the right um and then the right
hand cross over the left we're just
putting them back to back with each
other right so when we do a five beat
weave what we're doing is we're twisting
our arms around each other so rather
than the left hand going over the right
we have the left hand going on top of
the right and then the right curling
back around under it to lead back over
to the other side of your body so rather
than the left going on top to lead you
over to the right hand side or the right
going on top to lead you over to the
left hand side you have the right hand
reaching from underneath to carry you
over to the right and you have the left
hand reaching from underneath to carry
you over to the left you can practice
this by just doing it one side at a time
so we wrap them around and come back we
wrap them around and come back you're
really kind of like wrapping your wrists
around each other such that the
underhand is curling all the way over to
be on top of the other one that's what
takes you over so you want to practice
switching your timing around so that
it's the right hand that leads back over
to the right hand side curl your wrists
around each other do that a bunch of
times and then you work on it on your uh
right side where it'll be the left hand
curling around
whoops underneath your right hand so
that uh you curl them around enough so
that the left hand winds up on top and
that takes you back over to the
left so we try left hand
leads left hand leads left hand leads
and then we can switch to right hand
left hand right hand left hand or you
can do the same one a few times in a row
so
one
2 3 and then switch
2 three and then switch and try and do
one
two and switch
one two and then switch and just do
one and
switch and one and switch and when you
get to the point where you're just doing
one and switch one and switch one and
switch congratulations you are doing a
5B
weave
nice
Coolio what else we got in here
um Ras asks have you been to Lithuania I
have not I have not um I
um I have the furthest East in Europe
I've ever been is the Czech Republic um
it'd be fun to to go visit that area
though um my family is Finnish so I I
would love to to go visit Finland in
Estonia and of course Lithuania is right
next to Estonia so that that' be a good
old time um so nope never been it'd be
fun to go I think though it'd be fun to
go um Yulan asked about five beat weaves
again okay well you got your explanation
sir um Jillian says thank you for
explaining this I really appreciate it
you're welcome
um Sonic Hill says hi Drex what advice
would would you give to somebody who
wants their po fire reignited oh my
god um well I hope they I the first
thing I would probably say is uh go
please share that advice with me because
definitely uh things have been tough
lately I'm not going to lie um I don't
know I I I I I
don't so the thing that usually carries
me through with anything related to like
oh you know I want the fire reignited or
you know I want more motivation or what
have you is um I don't trust in
motivation I motivation is fickle I
trust in
discipline um when you make a regular
appointment to practice and show up
every single time every like whether
it's daily or every other day or once a
week or what have you and you just make
that
you make a date with yourself and you
always keep that date
um what I tend to find is that
ultimately the Fulfillment comes from
the practice um you're no longer looking
for like oh you know I haven't had a new
trick and in so long or you know oh I
feel like my my flow is is uh is really
stale or anything like that um you just
come to appreciate the practice itself
as an end unto it
itself um and then the question of
motivation and like the fire to spin um
I I think kind of it it almost
disappears in a way because it you
realize that um you realize the the the
the question is not how to make it um
stimulating again the question is how do
you look at the practice that you have
and uh create a relation ship with that
um cuz and I think you're more or less
asking the same question of like you
know what happens when you find yourself
on a plateau or something like
that um and the answer is that look you
you you have to you have to learn to
love the plateau no matter what skill
you learn in life the majority of the
time that you spend engaging in that
skill you're going to be on a plateau
it's it's just a given there's no way
around it and so you have to learn to um
appreciate the plateau and see the
plateau as an opportunity to um deepen
your learning and um polish the things
you learned in your last creative burst
and yeah just over time that becomes the
end unto itself is is the practice um I
hope I'm I'm answering the question
properly there it might it if if you are
literally asking me how to save an old
set of firep or something like that
please let me know if I'm if I'm taking
this off in in like direct free
association mode or what have you but I
think that's the question you're asking
and honestly my my answer
is create a regular practice routine um
and hold on to it no matter what uh and
eventually the practice becomes the end
unto
itself um and you get fulfillment out of
the practice just showing up and doing
it is is all you need to do in order to
to you know feel that that dopamine hit
of you know hey I accomplished something
you know so that would be what I would
say uh Ras is now asking will you come
to Europe for some po meetings I don't
know um it is expensive for me to get to
Europe and uh most of
so whenever I've gone to a PO Meetup um
it tends to be that I have somebody
helping me out and subsidizing my travel
um I I I don't think I don't see an
opportunity for me to do that in Europe
anytime soon but who knows maybe maybe
there will be some Festival uh in Europe
that will really want me to come and
will be happy to uh to to Spring uh to
to help me make the trip over there I
would really appreciate that uh I really
would but um yeah I think otherwise it's
going to be pretty difficult for me to
make it over unfortunately um I will say
that
uh my my plan was actually to do the
European juggling convention in 2020
because it was being held in
Finland and I wanted to visit Finland I
wanted to reconnect with the land of my
ancestors and um as we all know Co got
in the way and then it did the year
after and so uh
ejc in Finland will end up happening
completely online so if there's when and
if there's another ejc in Finland um I
would be more likely to prioritize that
but otherwise yeah I'm almost certainly
going to need somebody to help uh to
help subsidize my travel unfortunately
them's the
breaks um shrimp says Sonic make
challenges out of spinning try using one
hand or only spinning One Direction or
on one plane New Tricks listen to new
music
so this might be unpopular but I'm I'm
gonna push back on this because
fundamentally you're still seeking the
thing that I think Sonic Hill is which
is how do I get my dopamine fixed here
how do I get something new and novel how
do I get something that is going to feel
new to me
and we live in a world of constant
distractions and constant dopamine hits
from all corners and the problem with
that is is that it it it desensitizes us
to
stimulation and
so the quest there is not to find new
ways
of of of getting stimulation of getting
those dopamine hits um the quest is to
be able to find a way to love something
without constantly getting those
dopamine hits cuz spoilers no matter
what challenges you give yourself
you're going to run out of them and
you're going to be just left with you
and the prop and no new stimulus so if
you can't make your peace with
that on a long enough timeline you're
not going to stick with it um so I think
I I don't think it's
a giving yourself new challenges that's
fine to do but I think the real work is
in finding how to appreciate something
without the constant
stimulation um cuz you'll come up with
challenges over time sure but the
majority of time that you spend engaging
in a skill and more specifically pois
spinning you're going to have to do it
without that constant stimulation so
learning to learning to appreciate it
even without it that's the real
challenge there and without that again
just it's not a question of if it's a
question of when you run out of steam
there and decide to move on to something
else that does give you like and this is
the way I see a lot of people kind of
approach learning skills is
to is to basically jump from new thing
to new thing because every time you try
a new thing you get that dopamine hit
and so you wind up with people who have
like they
have kind of a uh a a basic familiarity
with a lot of things but they never get
really in depth on any one thing
and I think that's a shame I I I think
that there's a lot of benefit in um
working towards something on a on a deep
level and to do that you have to be
willing to make your peace with it not
always being stimulating so um Ulen says
thank you for explaining this I app I
really appreciate it you're so welcome
you're so welcome uh shrimp asks any
tips on changing directions while doing
the Mercedes on wall plane changing
directions you mean switching the
direction of the
Mercedes
um sure
is um so
like so the way I always try to teach
the Mercedes is I I try and have people
learn it one segment at a time going
back and forth between points of it so
like you've got you know one diagonal
segment you've got another horizontal
segment you've got uh this diagonal
segment right here and you can start
putting together pairs of these points
and go back and forth along them and
that in my mind is the a good way to
build up the Mercedes and it also means
that whenever you get to one of those
Corners you can pretty much
automatically just switch the direction
of it whenever you want to
like
so so yeah if if you train by building
up the Mercedes segment by segment in
that way um it's it's pretty easy to to
switch directions on the Fly the the the
thing to bear in mind is like whether
it's here here or here you're looking
for the corners of that triangle in the
uh in the tri ketra and when you hit one
of those Corners you can switch your
direction pretty easily the key is to
look out for the corners that's where
you can make the change that's where you
can make the
change Coolio again friends just as a
reminder if you want to bump your
question up in the queue uh you can
leave a super chat um which also comes
directly to me and supports the channel
so and also you can just support the
channel if you'd like to I I'm I'm
totally meable to all that but that's a
good way to get your question bumped up
in the queue um Omar Morales hey Omar
how you doing man uh when is the next
time you're coming to Columbus good
question
um I'm really really really hoping to uh
well if all goes according to plan I'm
hoping to come back in March and if that
doesn't happen then um the the plan will
be to come back uh probably in in in May
um I want to come back sooner I really
do um but uh things have been
challenging on mind end I'm afraid um
but yeah as soon as I can is is is the
real answer to that
question yeah
um Eileen says how many hours a day do
you dedicate to practice lessons editing
oh my
god um so let's talk about today shall
we um so my day started off with uh Med
ation running and stretching and I got
done with all of that at about 10:
a.m. uh I posted some videos to online
uh these are my um these are my uh uh
whatam jig um sponsored videos from
Ultra PO for the month um and that took
me like an hour I want to say I did did
some uh budgeting for the coming month
that took us to noon and
um let's see
here ate lunch got back to work at 1:00
I had my first private lesson of the day
at 2 it went to 3 no excuse me my first
private lesson of the day was at 3 I
went out and flowed for 40 minutes
before I had to teach my first private
lesson
uh came back in so first private lesson
I had an hour between that and my second
private lesson and then I had all of 40
minutes uh of downtime before setting up
for this uh no that's a lie I had to set
up within 20 minutes but I I had 40
minutes uh in between my last private
lesson getting out and doing this so I
would really count that as uh basically
me starting work at at 10:00 a.m. uh
having a lunch break that was like maybe
30 40 minutes um and I'm going to get
done with this call at
8 um
so yeah what is that
like uh 10 hour
day is that right 10 hours yeah because
I got started at 10: a.m. so 10 hour day
yay
um the answer to how many hours a day I
spend practicing is not nearly as many
as I would like um yeah I I only got in
like 40 minutes today overall because
there were so many other things going on
um but yeah I um I spend a lot of time
doing this as the long and short of it
um and and it depends upon the day and
it depends upon the workload today was
was pretty exceptional I should have
been done after 8 hours but then there
was this to do um so yeah a lot is is
the short
answer um Sonic Hill says that's exactly
what I was asking hence why I put fire
in quotes awesome uh glad to GL glad to
give you a solid answer there then uh
Ras is asking is there any chance you
will do a workshop with Nick woy in the
future um I mean maybe the CH there are
some pretty big challenges to that
though
um so for those of you who don't know um
Nick Wolsey can't te well he can he can
uh come to the United States but like so
Nick wiy got caught uh coming across the
border to teach in the United States uh
in the mid 2000s and because of that he
he he didn't have a work permit and they
deported him and it was something like 5
years before he could re-enter the
United States and now since he's been
deported once already they're going to
be looking real carefully at the
circumstances under which he's he's
crossing the border
so he would need a work permit to uh
teach in the United States and as of
right now hey thank you for the Super
Chat Eileen
yay uh let me know if you have a
question that you would like answered
and I will bump it up in the cube I
really appreciate that thank you so
much um so we would need to have a work
permit for for Nick in order to come
down and teach workshops in the United
States and I it
is it is questionable as to whether or
not the amount of money he could make
off of teaching workshops down here in
the United States would offset the cost
of him uh getting that work permit to to
come uh to to to teach here so that
would mean
the other another possibility would be
me going up to Canada uh in teaching
with him and actually one time that was
the plan there was going to be a year
that I was going to go up and teach at
Leviathan with him um and it kind of
broke down over time partially because
um Leviathan is really really remote
it's incredibly hard to get to and
um
I just in in breaking down what it was
going to take to get me there and also
too like there was
um um there there was basically like the
system was set up such that like um in
promoting
it I I was meant to sell a certain
number of tickets um in in order to to
make it work for both of us and they got
to be a point at which the the numbers
just just didn't work out anymore um and
so
uh I wound up backing out of that one um
and I don't know I'm I'm curious to see
how his workshops are going to work out
this
year
um I uh given where the flow Community
is right now both financially and in
terms of participation I'm a little
skeptical of inperson events right now
just just in general
um so we'll see what happens and maybe
this is a is a successful year for Nick
and maybe he and I can try doing
something either next year or the year
after but for right now that seems like
too big a Financial Risk to me
um but may there might be a possibility
of doing something like that in the
future and then of course like maybe
somewhere else in the
world maybe Europe as as people may be
asking for um again the challenge is the
money I I cannot afford to take a loss
on on on going and teaching somewhere
and the further and further it is away
from home the higher the number gets
that we've got to we we we've we've got
to uh kind of cancel out there and I I
think anywhere other than the United
States or Canada any place that isn't
like immediately accessible to either
him or I um that number probably becomes
insurmountable unless there there is
some external Force at like um we were
going to do a workshop tour and go
through multiple cities or um we like
there was a sponsor for the tour some
company that would uh that would like
have their logo in the uh in the
workshop tour that would offset
costs um but I don't see those pieces
lining up right
now uh yeah which sucks because I think
he's a cool guy I would like to teach
with him uh I met him uh the one and
only time I've taught in Vancouver uh he
showed up to it was at a place called
Mad Skills and it was really fun meeting
him we we we had really awesome talks uh
and he showed up to uh a couple of my
workshops which let me tell you was
nerve-wracking as all get out oh my God
Nick Wy walks into your class and all of
a sudden you're just kind of like this
is not my
aame
no uh but he was really really nice uh
we we like each other as people um I
think it'd be fun to teach with him but
yeah I mean bottom line is is you know I
I there are things that I do for fun and
I I I can't afford to go teach a set of
workshops in another country uh without
being without knowing that I'm not going
to take a loss on it so that's that's
really what it boils down
to um oh my
hello again asks what's Finnish food
like can you cook it um there are some
Finnish dishes that I can cook including
um one that I just recently discovered
is actually a Sami dish that that uh my
family uh I I used to eat growing up and
uh it's it's a kind of Stew called beos
um and it's originally it's supposed to
be um reindeer and carrots and um I want
to say there's potatoes and barley in it
too and um yeah mom used to make that
when we were growing up really really
hearty she would usually make that up
with um a type of uh finish bread called
uh rasa which is I want to say it's oat
based uh and we used to you know it it
doesn't really rise it's not leavened um
so you like cut it up into slices and
you put honey on it and you eat that
with uh with the beos and it's it's it's
delicious um the finished food that I do
cook every single year though is um
every year for Christmas I bake uh yolu
the uh the finish uh the literal
translation is Christmas tart um they
they're like they have four points to
them there's a jelly that you put in the
middle of it they are delightful look up
photos online of finished Tarts um
that's what I make uh every December for
for Christmas
um so yeah there there's
um there's some other stuff that my mom
used to make when I was growing up like
um so I found out in most of Finland uh
there's a type of bread called uh Pula
which
um we I'm trying to remember the term
that we used for it um
cuz our fames from uh the north part of
fin in sap me um and there's a different
term there's apparently a different term
for it up there
um oh what's the name of it it's a it's
a cardamom uh flavored bread
um oh I'm so mad at myself for uh for
for for getting what this is called
it'll come back to me or maybe I can
maybe I can look it up as I'm saying and
as as I'm on here and uh save some face
here
um please
hold nissu that's it that's it uh we we
call it nissu um I've never baked it but
I like it a lot it's very tasty uh I
highly recommend um there's actually a
finished Bakery here in DC that um I
I'll go down uh during the holiday
season and pick up uh a loaf of nissu
and uh and try out their yoru which if I
do say so myself my family's version of
uh yoru is much better but we we we can
uh we we can uh we can quibble on that
and put them head to-head
sometime yeah so those are some examples
of Finnish food that uh I I I ate
growing up and uh and some that that I
can that I can still cook I I've never
made a beos myself um we would
substitute either beef or elk um for the
reindeer portion of it but um yeah I I I
know how to make it so if I wanted to I
could I could definitely make it up but
uh yeah those are some good examples of
finished food thanks for the question
Omar um shrim says thanks Roka says what
is your opinion about old school fir
flow I mean I like a lot of it um
there's a gentleman who has been posting
regularly in poy chat lately Jake loves
art that is actually like went back and
um picked out some of his favorite
videos from the old school era there's
some UTA in there uh there's some xan
Moore uh and I I think that there's some
awesome stuff in those videos um I I I I
definitely have a bias on this but um
I person you know what I'm going to do I
if I'm not up and running around the
room I'm going to turn that off because
that looks like it's really obnoxious um
but yeah uh Wiman jig um so one thing I
really really appreciate about the old
school flow people is that like just as
performers they did such an amazing job
of playing around with volume and levels
and we really lost that
at one point in the PO world like as
soon as the tech tree just became the
dominant posture for
everybody I feel like we we kind of lost
a lot of those old Dynamics in uh the
old uh style of fir flow and I miss it
I'm I as you can see I'm I'm trying to
bring back elements of it um yeah the
video this guy posted of Utah was just
phenomenal I feel like when it comes to
poy
dance Nick and UTA really like crack the
code in a lot of ways and in trying
to figure out aspects of Po dance myself
it's amazing how often I will like come
to a point where I'm just like oh my God
I just made a breakthrough and I'm
feeling really proud of myself and then
I'll go watch an old Utah or Nick video
I'm just like oh they already knew how
to do this stuff of course they did of
course they did so there's a lot of
great gems back in there for sure
um yeah so uh I I love all that uh you
know I reference dervish Le yours all
the time just because like you know not
just because Flowers really just change
the way that everybody spends POI but
also it's a really remarkable
performance like Nick basically invents
all the conventions of modern po
performance in that video we're still
living in that Epoch in so many ways um
so yeah I I love I love the old fir flow
stuff yeah for sure uh Jillian asks how
do you do a buzz soft
fountain or excuse me I'm I'm going to
say it the way I normally would
Fountain I
uh there was a really funny moment
several years ago when
um uh I was at a friend's house and for
some reason one of my we were talking
about my videos and we watched one of
them and one of the guys who was there
who I had never met before he kind of
turns to me he's like why is your accent
different in your videos and um I had
another conversation about that quite
recently and so it I there are times
when I like catch myself doing it now
where it's just like you you you would
never never say fountain in your normal
life it would always be Fountain to you
and so there there are times when I I
I'm just like dude really uh anyway so
um buz saww Fountain um because there's
a gladle stop in it if you're from
Colorado um so Buzz sawt Fountain 101
start off with a forwards buz saww over
on your stage right then you do a
reverse buzzsaw over on your stage left
now you have to get back and forth
between them how do you do that I'm so
glad you asked from the forward buz saw
your left hand is going to reach down
and around and it's going to reach out
and over to your stage left side you're
going to keep your Poise spinning split
time Same Direction with your hands off
to either side now your right hand is
going to come around and join the left
hand and create a reverse Buzz saw now
your right hand is going to take off and
return back over to your right side
again you're going to hang out with your
pois spinning split Time same direction
here in wall plane and then your left
hand is going to come around and join it
in Buzz saw so we have left hand goes
left right hand goes right left right
hand goes right left hand goes right now
the next step is we want to try
and narrow up those gaps so think left
right right left left right right left
like so and already you're starting see
elements of it appear now the next piece
of this is that we have to kind of
narrow up those gaps between the hands
moving back and forth here so try and
hold the hands closer together as you're
going to either
side like
so and when you can keep that pretty
consistent congratulations that is a buz
saww fountain or Fountain if you
prefer um also does need to be said uh
realize comparatively recently that when
you're performing this buz saw Fountain
um both of the poy are performing three
petal inpin flowers there is a way to do
this so that you do two two petal uh
inpin flowers it goes a lot faster I
feel like it looks a lot wonkier too
because one of the benefits of doing uh
three pedal
inpin flowers as you're going around
here uh is that it feels kind of
balanced and symmetrical so I have my
moments where uh I have a recognizable
buz saw on either side of my body and if
I remember how to do this
right yeah so if I do this as a pair of
two petal ins spin flowers I basically
lose that moment where I can resolve to
a uh a full Buzz saw on the left side of
my body I only have a real Buzz saw on
my right side so both are possibilities
the thing we think of as being a buz
saww fountain
um
definitely is the three pedal
version
um so that's probably where you want to
start yeah Wy hampson hello Wy uh Drex
just wanted to say that I started
spending po at the start of the year and
I have already learned a ton thanks to
your videos thank you and thank you sir
I'm glad to hear that I'm glad to hear
that
um Eileen asks if you won $80 million
after tax that is a
remarkably
remarkably specific number Eileen I know
I'm wondering if you know something that
I don't
uh if you won $80 million after
tax which that would probably drop it
down to closer to 40 million but still a
good number to work with
um what would your plan
be oh my goodness I mean probably to
invest the vast majority of it make sure
that the money grows
um I live in Washington DC so I would
definitely uh I would definitely buy a
house in the city at that point um cuz
that's the only way I'm going to have
enough money in the bank to do that um
but yeah the vast majority of it I would
invest make sure that the that the money
grows over time um maybe create an
endowment or something um
I yeah man I'd have to think about that
for a while cuz I
I think it would be good
to invest some money in um the cultural
preservation of uh of Mau po um maybe
see about funding um some of the schools
in New Zealand that uh teach M kids the
uh traditional form of uh of uh kapahaka
um
[Music]
especially with POI
um and also just on a personal level too
um I'm Sami and there
are I'm sure there are some uh there are
some projects uh back in sapi uh in
Norway and Sweden and Finland to
preserve the culture that would be worth
investing in um so yeah I those are some
things I can think of off the top of my
hand I don't really have like an $80
million plan on the top of my head like
that's
uh
oh okay here's one thing here's one
thing here here would be my Rockstar
moment for that
um
so there is a sculpture Studio based in
Vietnam called declay studio and they
create these hyper realistic
Miniatures really really anatomically
accurate dinosaurs
I would absolutely buy every single
miniature they currently have
um yeah they're they're incredibly
detailed they're super scientifically
accurate they're gorgeous that they're
they're beautifully painted I I that
would be my Rockstar moment is to make
sure that I had declay Studio dinosaurs
all over the house yeah yeah that
wouldn't that wouldn't eat up the whole
the whole 80 million but uh I think we
can I think we can set aside a couple
hundred for uh for cool dinosaur models
for sure
um Wy hampson asks what are your
favorite poy to practice with at
home same ones I've been using on this
live stream my sock po uh from Socko and
neop poy um yeah they the feel of them
is fantastic they're super soft um
they're so portable they fit in my
shoulder I take them everywhere with me
um they show up beautifully on camera
um literally my only problem with them
really is I mean I wish I wish the ends
were slightly wider so that they'd show
up just slightly better on camera and
also too um they're made out of a pretty
resilient canvas but it's not resilient
enough as as you might be able to see I
use these very heavily and I definitely
have like worn through uh a a good
amount of the material here um I would
love a slightly more rugged material for
them but other than that they're
phenomenal and I adore them uh those are
the ones that I use for uh for for damn
near
everything dizzy is giving me is is is
uh is is is dead over there laughing at
me I'm guessing that's because I was
talking about Fountain versus
Fountain
um so that's a while ago now Ras is
asking what do you think about bringing
back the old school flow pants that were
very you know you mean the old jeno
jeans uh except for flow artists uh that
were very wide and used by Nick and
other performers back in the day would
love to hear your opinion about
performance outfits um I think those
pants work great if you're going to
adopt some really Dynamic poses
um they're not the right answer for
everything though and you know that same
guy who uh posted the old videos of Zan
and Nick and um uh and UTA in po chat he
also posted an old video of me
performing where I'm wearing those pants
and I'm wearing them as I'm doing a
performance where I'm mostly doing Tech
trees and they look awful like they're
they're not good pants for for doing
Tech Tree stuff in um so I think it
depends upon the I think if you're going
to move around a lot if you're going to
like do some dramatic poses and actually
engage your legs then they're great yeah
um
I you know I I I I still have my set in
the closet I don't think I've I don't
think I've pulled those out in probably
a good like six seven years maybe
um but uh yeah I mean they have their
purpose um I don't necessarily think
that I think of them as like default
performance wear I think honestly that
like
[Music]
um what you wear in the performance
depends upon how you choreographed it
and there there are a lot of right
answers and the giant jeno Jean uh flow
pants are not the right answer to all of
them but they are the right answer to
some of them um definitely seeing UDA
flow in them was always a treat like
that man just like the way he engages
every part of his body and his spinning
is is just beautiful to behold sure the
the chef's kiss there not the blowing a
kiss my bad
um but uh yeah they they um they they
have their uses I honestly me personally
I would like to see a lot people try a
lot more different options for for flow
performances cuz I feel like we've got
like the old school flow jinx jeans
pants we've got um people doing either
goth or pastel goth stuff um and we've
got kind of like Festival W wear and
those are like really the only three
options that anybody ever chooses for
performance and I would I I'd just like
to see us Explore More territory like Po
has so much range as a prop I think it
really it it's a shame when we box it in
and um
you know when we don't explore the full
range of that
so yeah very very long answer on those
uh on on those flow
pants uh Jillian says thank you for
explaining this and this tick seems so
trick and seems so interested to learn
cool glad to hear it um Sonic Hill asks
what's your process on creating one of
your monthly
videos let me get to your first question
first
um so it depends it depends on what the
video
is but if it's um
so the usual process the so it depends
on the video it depends on the month but
like in Broad
Strokes um the first thing is generally
planning out with the video is going to
be I need to have a topic in mind and um
it's not at all rare I have um some
tools that I use for keyword research on
YouTube uh to help me figure out what
people are searching for so what I will
do is I will uh take what I want to
teach and I will see if I can find a
searchable keyword that I can associate
with it and once I have that in place um
I will either create an outline or a
script um if it's an outline what I'll
generally do is um set up in my living
room I used to just only have a single
camera for setup I now uh I now use both
my Sony camera as well as my iPhone 15
Pro and what I'll do is I'll set up both
cameras so I have a close-up camera as
well as a wide angle and I will go
through the outline I have for my
lesson very very important um whenever
so whenever I'm recording um if I blow a
line I snap my finger once if I get the
line I snap it twice reason for this
being that when I get the video into my
editing program
afterwards um I actually don't watch the
entire video that I recorded what I do
is I go and I search for the blocks of
text that are bookended by the the
snapping
fingers I can just see that in the audio
waveform in the editing program so um I
just go through and only take the the
portions that I know I got the line once
I have that I will edit back and forth
between the close angle and the far
angle um I will do any kind of text or
anything like that that I need to
include I'll stick in the title sequence
uh text overlays things like that
um I usually have to do a little bit of
color grading uh I export the
video upload the video um at that point
I have to go through the very painful
process of uh creating a thumbnail and
writing out the description usually I
take the keyword research that I did for
the video and I will apply that when
you're doing the keyword research
generally speaking the uh the the app
that I use for doing that will also
include other Associated keywords in it
so I'll build the description around the
original keyword and the ass ated
keywords and then the thumbnail is just
straight up sorcery um it's black
magic sometimes you get it right
sometimes you don't uh YouTube now has
it set up so that you can upload three
different variations of your thumbnail
and you can see which one is the most
effective and after two weeks um it'll
automatically select the most um uh the
most effective thumbnail at getting
clicks as being the default
thumbnail um and then it's down to
promoting it online you know take a
segment out to post to
Instagram um do postings on Twitter on
Facebook on
threads promote the
thing uh make it available early for my
patreon
subscribers um and then set it to
publish and see how it did and once it
has published and I see how it
performed um I will
incorporate that knowledge into the next
few videos that I create so it's it's
kind of uh an aobos in some ways
um I used to produce more content and
the way that I made that worked was that
I would batch uh parts of the production
process so I would plan out and write
multiple videos at a time usually like
two or three at a time and when I went
to go film I would shoot two to three
videos in a single shoot um which was
great because it meant that I always had
like a back catalog of content and
generally speaking that meant that there
was like anywhere between like a two to
3 week um kind of buffer for me so any
video that you saw from me back in
2023 um had actually been shot at least
two weeks before you saw it um so that
was really handy because it meant that I
was head of deadlines things have
changed a lot for me uh recently and I'm
more prone to just like oh you know I
have this idea and I just get up and
shoot it rather than doing a lot of that
planning ahead of time um but yeah that
that was that was the process uh the oh
monthly po videos as in one of the flow
videos oh shoot okay so that's a
different process I have to I have to
find a place that I want to go in DC to
shoot the video I will pick a song um um
I will select my wardrobe I will do my
best to remember the colors of whatever
the background is and select colors that
will contrast with it I don't I'm not
always successful in that regard uh I
pack up my backpack with uh my camera my
PO um and uh my
tripod and of course a Bluetooth speaker
I will go to that local I will set up my
camera I will wait until the lighting is
uh
ideal and I will do several takes of the
song usually what I do is I'll uh have
it running off of my iPhone and I will
set the song to automatically record I
will you know move the slider over until
there's like 30 seconds left of the song
I will set the camera going I'll just go
put myself in place and when the song
automatically Loops I'll begin the
performance I'll go back and check and
see if that was the performance that I
wanted if it's not I'll do more takes
bring it home um I've talked before
about the process of adding trails to my
footage go through that process the rest
of it the same do keyword research
create the thumbnail post it share it
see how it did and uh decide what I'm
going to do next based upon based upon
that uh that data yeah
so if that sounds like a lot that's
because it
is so um Sonic hill now asks also have
you had an opportunity uh I assume you
mean to say play with the uh flow toys
Coral poy uh have you had an opportunity
to work with or play with the flow toys
Coral poy no no I have not
um I think it is probably going to be a
while before
I work with the set of coral
poy I think it's going to be a while
um I'm not going to go into detail as to
why that is but um um I suspect it'll be
a while if I ever do
um but yes I I have not had uh excuse me
no the answer is I have not had an
opportunity to work with uh the the
coral poy as of yet um Julian danin asks
how do you do atomic
crossers I don't
know I don't
actually uh hang on
okay
so I don't know how to do them
horizontal plane versus vertical
plane
but I could see doing
them vertical plane versus vertical
plane
ooh so this is a normal Crosser if I can
I
yeah I guess I can so this is a Crosser
done in
atomic planes so my right hand POI that
is the orange one is in wheel plane my
yellow POI is
in uh wall plane this is really funky
and kind of difficult because they would
Clash into each other and tangle but um
yeah what I would honestly say is once
you got a Crosser down pick one hand
that you're going to stick into wheel
plane and that'll turn into your Atomic
Crosser right
there yeah that would do it that would
do
it also I think yeah we are getting uh
we are past the hour friends so I'm
going to answer the questions that are
currently in the queue and then I'm
going to wrap things up for the night
cuz I need to
eat
um so
uh Ras says I have to go thank you so
much for your opinions and it was fun
talking to you Drex thank you it's fun
talking to you too you're always welcome
in Lithuania and you are the teacher of
Lithuanian flow artists thank you I
really appreciate that I really
appreciate that
Ras Logan asks do you host inperson po
classes um I host in-person private
lessons but not uh inperson group
classes I've just found that it's too
difficult
to um to get access to stud Studio space
in the DC
area um maybe maybe at some point I'll
go back to doing uh inperson classes I
would certainly like to but um yeah the
demand just wasn't there last time uh I
tried so yeah again I I can't afford to
take losses on the on
classes
um I don't know how to read that name
asks how to practice split time outward
butterfly flow
um split time outward butterfly
flow I mean I I if I'm understanding
your question correctly I think you just
work on getting down um a bunch of
outward butterfly based poy tricks and
work on the transitions between them
like if you keep timing and Direction
consistent
uh it's it's usually pretty easy to flow
between py tricks that that use the same
timing and Direction on stuff I'm sorry
I would give you a longer answer than
that but I've already stayed on later
than I intended to so um I do need to
wrap things up because I am very hungry
at this point um but thank you everybody
for your wonderful questions tonight and
thank you especially to uh eileene for
your super chat I really really
appreciate it uh Julian says thank you
for explaining this I really appreciate
all your knowledge about different
tricks I am sorry for putting you on the
spot for this trick it's okay it happens
um yeah so I'm going to go ahead and
wrap things up then friends um thank you
all so much for joining me this evening
uh I hope you had a great time and I
hope you join me for my next impromptu
live stream in March um take care and uh
yeah be safe out there friends I will
see you soon and uh yeah if you if you
enjoyed this video or the videos on my
channel you're not already please uh go
check out my patreon at patreon.com
drexfactor poo I have uh live stream
classes that are available right now
over on crowdcast
doio dfactor PO um that you can tune
into from anywhere in the world
um yeah so thank you all for joining me
um take care and be good I'll see you
soon friends
peace for